on a crisp morning in june
snowflakes spread its wings and let the
strong wind of guadalupe island
help it take a first flight away from
its home
this wasn't the first time the young
black-footed albatross had soared above
the north pacific ocean
five months before as an egg scientists
flew snowflakes 6
000 kilometers from midway atoll in
hawaii
black-footed albatrosses can spend years
without touching land
but they return every year to mate and
nest in the islands where they were born
midway atoll makes up about one-third of
the global breeding population alone
there they nest on low-lying sandy
beaches
but this makes their eggs and chicks
very vulnerable to sea level rise
and flooding in 2011 a tsunami wiped out
about
30 000 of their nests on three atolls
the international union for conservation
of nature
lists the black-footed albatross as well
as their close cousin
the lacin albatross as near-threatened
since their breeding grounds are in
peril so are their populations
so scientists from mexico at grupo de
cologia
conservacion de islas and in the u.s
from pacific rim conservation had the
bold idea
to re-establish a population of
black-footed albatrosses
in a safer location scientists placed 21
eggs in incubators and flew them from
midway to guadalupe island
they traveled four legs on this journey
from private jets to domestic flights
on extra comfort rows the island is a
reserve
where black-footed albatross and other
seabirds once
nested feral cats introduced in the mid
20th century ended the colony but
scientists with hissy have been working
on the island for the past
20 years to eradicate invasive species
they've made progress but in the
meantime an excluder fence erected in
2014
keeps the southern part of the island
free of threats
after the long journey the midway eggs
met their foster parents
experienced lace and albatross pears
when
18 eggs hatched in february the new
parents fed
and cared for their adopted chicks
since scientists didn't know how well
lace and parents would raise the
imported eggs
they decided to also try the
translocation experiment with chicks
the team selected black-footed albatross
chicks and covered them at night
so they would not learn the hawaiian sky
and imprint there
the scientists repeated the journey
across the pacific in february
of 2021 after transporting the
one-month-old chicks to guadalupe island
jesse's team hand-reared them the chicks
were exposed to decoys and recorded
vocalizations of their species
they monitored the babies daily and fed
them until they were ready to fly away
all have done so translocations are not
first-line
interventions for saving species but
sometimes they're the only option
in the past 30 years a variety of
animals have been translocated
the conservation community hopes the
experiment with black-footed albatross
breaks ground for other similar projects
after the success of the lace and foster
parents the team is planning to bring at
least 80 more black-footed albatross
eggs to guadalupe island in the next few
years
but they won't know how well the project
works until snowflake
and the rest of the first batch return
in five
years to start looking for mates
when they do the scientists will be
waiting for them with open
arms
[Music]
you